Megan is in Chicago hi Megan welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up I am a
newer listener so forgive me for my
ignorance I am on baby step two we have
our thousand dollar savings and we're
currently working on our debt we have
about thirty four thousand dollars and
that includes our cars we do not have a
mortgage we currently rent now my
question is we're gonna have this paid
off within the next two years maybe even
a year right now we have a plan that we
wanted to take our children into an RV
for about two years and travel the
country however we would have to finance
to get this RV and something to tow it
with we feel like time is of the essence
since our kids are getting older so we
would not like to wait if possible but I
just wanted to see what your advice for
something like this would be it's a neat
dream I like having the dream I feel
cool very cool well Megan I don't tell
people to borrow money because every
time I find people borrowing money I
find broke people right and and if you
borrow on something that goes down in
value as fast as an RV does I'm gonna
find really broke people have you ever
tried to sell a used RV yeah possible to
get rid of them they're hard to get
financing on and they go down in value
faster than almost anything with wheels
and motors they are mathematically
horrendous they were just a mess and so
the other the other one is a big medium
sized boat if you get a hundred million
dollar boat you can get financing on it
and if you get a cheap bass boat you can
get financing on it but the middle range
of boats the 50 to 150 thousand is a
difficult product and so you just about
have to have the money to just consume
it and be able to afford it so what I
would tell you do what's your household
income it's about sixty thousand okay I
would get myself out of debt I'd work
extra jobs and then I would save up and
pay cash for
or an RV that would that would surf ice
for the two-year period of time and then
if you sell it at somewhat of a loss at
least you've got you don't need ed on it
and you don't get caught in it it's not
a problem it doesn't ruin your life
going forward because if you take a
wonderful dream like you have and you
finance it you're gonna turn it into a
nightmare
right it's gonna cause a problem for
your family because I mean you put a
hundred grand in an RV but the time you
get home it's worth fifty great and
you're gonna be stuck and owing all that
money and you know you're gonna you
can't mess up your kids college plan
you're gonna mess up your retirement I
mean it could be disastrous if you do
this wrong and so what I do save up and
buy one or look for some a program where
you can rent one for two years if you
can do that for two years and just turn
it back in I doubt there is one they're
probably very very expensive I know you
can rent them short-term for the weekend
and those aren't bad deals but a
two-year plan is different and when you
add all of this up it might be that you
guys could stay and you're you could
travel in your car or your SUV or
whatever it is you own and stay in
hotels cheaper by the time you add it
all up because you're going to lose so
much money on this transaction and again
I'm not trying to ruin your dream I just
don't want your dream to be a nightmare
so do it with no debt you do it used and
and do some mathematical analysis on it
and you got some nights to do that while
you're working to get your other debts
paid off right now and then if you want
to save up 50 grand and buy a
three-year-old or a two-year-old hundred
grand thing or something and and then it
becomes worth 25 by the time you get
home I'm gonna be mad at you for that
that doesn't ruin your life but if you
just go write a check and finance
something you're gonna be in a mess
kiddo
and I don't want that for you I want you
to win hey thanks for the call